We um,
are starting to use primary sources
for our understanding of the historical
periods under discussion,
primary sources,
writings by people who lived at the time.
And as with all such sources,
the great advantage is vividness,
immediacy.
The people lived through it
and the problem is distance
from us and strangeness
Pro Copious and Gregory of tour who
will be starting out with next week are
varied. Different writers per copious, uh,
much more conscious of style.
A lay man,
somebody operating within
the classical tradition, uh,
Gregory of tour, certainly, uh,
uh,
a person for whom style is not paramount
or at least it's not the classical
notions of rhetoric, smoothness, uh,
and um, uh, vividness.
The per copious has,
he is a bishop.
He's very concerned with supernatural
events and the church or let's say
supernatural events controlled by the
church for copious as you've seen,
is not very concerned with Christianity
and the supernatural events that concern
him,
such as Justinian walking around the
palace with no head are not Christian
supernatural there.
They're from some other
older supernatural tradition,
but both Gregory of tour and per copious
require an effort to figure out why not
just read something by a writer historian
living now who may be easier to figure
out and who is writing with you and me
in mind because of the vividness and
because of the trickiness of trying
to reconstruct not only what happened,
which is hard enough,
but also what the mood of people
was and what the reaction was.
We're talking about Justinian
today. So, uh, a um,
uh,
emperor whose rule occupies most of the,
um,
sixth century five 27,
two five 65.
So we're concentrating on
the sixth century as part
of this overall survival and
crisis of the eastern Roman Empire,
his rain,
or more precisely the earlier part of
his reign until about five 40 is the
height apogee maximum
power of this empire,
which succeeds in,
shall we say,
reconquering or conquering,
taking back or adding the parts
of the western Roman empire,
many parts of the western Roman Empire
that had been lost effectively to the
barbarian invasions of the fifth century.
If you still can refer to your map or
if your memory of geography is okay.
Um,
the major areas of conquest of Justinian
beyond the borders of the old eastern
empire,
our first North Africa,
which is the coast of modern Libya,
Tunisia,
Algeria, uh, and even, uh, Morocco
held by the vandals
and seized by Justinian
parts of Spain, coastal
Spain, Mediterranean, Spain,
held by the Visigoths and
Italy held by the Ostrogoths.
This is the centerpiece
of Justinian's reign.
And for a time it looked
as if he had in effect,
recreated the empire of
Constantine and Diocletian.
But as we'll see, this is a, uh,
triumph with a terrible price,
the terrible price being
that we can Byzantium. Now,
when we say of paint figures in the
past or even figures in the recent past,
that, uh, their policies were a
mistake because it turned out that, uh,
uh, the, uh,
future enemy would be something
other than what they were fighting.
We can say that with the
advantage of being able to
see what was going to happen.
In other words,
you know,
there are people who argue that the
invasion of Iraq was a folly or that the
expenditures on the,
uh,
aggressive foreign policy of the first
years of the 20th first century was
foolish because as it turns out,
economic problems,
domestic problems, they, a mortgage a,
a bubble was really the problem that
people should have been addressing or they
should have been addressing the deficits.
You know, you can say that it's, it's in,
it's in it's own way.
It's a fact,
but it doesn't necessarily tell you what
people at the time should have thought
of.
Thus,
we know from last lecture
that first of all,
Justinian should have
concentrated on the Persians,
the Persians on his eastern
frontier who didn't interest him,
whom he just wanted to sort of pacify in
order to go west and make his conquest.
The Persians would turn out to be his big,
the biggest enemy of the empire.
And so,
you know,
if you were plotting this out as a kind
of international political strategy,
you could say,
uh,
forget about the Ostrogoths.
Forget about the vandals.
Build up that frontier, invade
Persia. Uh, keep your army there.
And indeed with a little more
hindsight, we can say, oh my gosh,
in 80 years, the Muslims are going to
take the eastern part of your empire.
Well,
obviously there's no way he is going
to be expected reasonably to know that
except if you're looking at a
distance from over a thousand years,
I was in 500 years. Uh, then,
you know, we can say, sure,
the eastern frontier turns out to
be the point of vulnerability. Uh,
so a classic kind of historical
problem or early Middle Ages,
midterm question is,
you know, Justinian um,
uh, overreach or, or reasonable, uh,
a guy or the conquest of the
West folly or a grand jury.
And it's both.
It is a classic example of
overextension overextension of empires,
meaning that empires weakened themselves
at some point fatally by simply getting
either too big or spending too
much money and the two are linked,
get too big. You have to spend
more money to defend your yourself,
not really having the resources to keep
what you have the British Empire to take
a, uh, a reasonably clear
and neutral example.
At some point is simply to, uh, large, uh,
for the resources of a
weakened Great Britain.
And, uh, our colleague Paul
Kennedy has explored, uh, uh,
quite memorably empires that simply
could not maintain their commitments.
The Spanish empire,
the British Empire.
And as it turned out after Kennedy wrote
his book, the Russian Soviet Empire,
this is a, a pattern
in history that is, uh,
that repeats itself.
The question,
however, is under the circumstances and
assuming the existence of that empire,
what are reasonable policies
to preserve it or to extend it?
We know about Justinian's wars
of conquest and of defense.
He did have some wars
against the Persians, uh,
his wars of conquest in defense,
largely,
although not exclusively
through pro copious,
but he is our best source in two works.
One, the secret history and
the other much more extensive,
a series of books called the wars.
And they're divided in Persian
wars, African wars, Italian wars
in the wars.
You can see that once the Italian
war starts to go badly per copious,
his opinion of Justinian and of the
great general Bellis areas tend to change
from a kind of admiration.
And Go kill,
get them spirit to,
um,
uneasiness to blaming to
a kind of finger pointing.
So we're dependent on pro copious.
And if when you first read the wars,
it seems very,
very different from the secret history.
It seems like it's by facilities or some
other sensible objective Greek writer
and he indeed is writing
in that tradition.
Those of you who've read
through cities will remember,
he describes often folly and very
terrible events, but soberly,
factually in a fashion of Olympians,
sorrow at the folly of
policymakers in generals.
And to some extent per
copious has that tone,
which seems to contrast very much with
the vehemence of the secret history.
Leading some people to assume that he was
crazy when he wrote the secret history
or off balance,
let's say,
or a that the war's represented,
uh,
the real pro copious and this
represented kind of his evil twin.
Uh, the term evil twin doesn't
appear in Gibbon, but uh, it could,
it could.
Um,
what makes it more complicated is
a third work of his cold buildings.
Buildings is,
as the name implies,
a book about Justinian's
building campaign,
which includes but is by no means limited
to the Church of Iso Fia in modern
Istanbul, which is, Eh,
continues to be to this day,
an extraordinary building
of such immensity and such
space in interior I dome
that sees unsupported by anything.
And that seems to cover half
the earth when you're inside it,
both splendid and an
extraordinary engineering fee.
And then, uh, interesting
Ian Built Churches, uh, uh,
he built churches.
That's a stand in Ravenna with
unbelievably beautiful mosaics,
Ravenna in Italy.
And these are important because Ravenna
was outside the zone of territory
controlled by the iconoclast.
And therefore,
while the icon of class tended to take
down or whitewash representations of
anything divine, uh, they're reached,
did not extend as far as Ravenna.
So in a way,
the best,
the best examples of Byzantine
Mosaic Art of the, uh,
earliest period, not in a way, but
absolutely are, uh, outside of the,
um, uh, the eastern
Mediterranean and in Italy.
Yeah.
Buildings though is not just an account
of Justinian's architectural essays,
but a Pennage lyric,
a praise of Justinian almost as slavish
Lee at Jula Tori as the secret history
is, um, a condemnation.
And as I suggested last time,
these actually go
together in a society of,
um,
were tremendous power is concentrated in
one person or one court or one setting.
The reactions of people
tend to be adulation,
which is to some extent forced
out of them or at least, uh,
invited by the ruler.
So again,
to take an obvious analogy,
Stalin for his 70th birthday was pleased
that the greatest museum of Moscow,
all the permanent exhibit was sort of
set aside and warehouse and the whole
museum was given over to gifts to Stalin
on his 70th birthday from a grateful
people. He didn't have to
order it. Somebody came up
with the idea and he said,
oh, uh, don't go to any trouble.
They had the thing that agile Latori,
this is what later would be called
the cult of personality is just one of
hundreds of examples of naming
cities after him. Uh, uh,
lauding him as the Great Gardner.
The friend of children, um,
the, uh, uh, a successor
of Lenin and so forth.
The other side of that is a
kind of hatred and diatribe,
more or less secret.
There were lots of jokes about Stalin
you could and people were sent to Siberia
or executed for telling these jokes,
but they were very good jokes
under the circumstances. Um,
this is some of the explanation for
how you can get at the same time,
adulation and demonization.
The interesting thing of course is
it's in the same guy for copious.
And although people at one time thought,
oh,
well he wrote the buildings earlier
and then became disillusioned,
he did become disillusioned.
Everybody became disillusioned because
after five 40 things started to go wrong,
there's a huge play getting five 42 that
kills off a third of the population for
starters. But it looks as if he's
writing this stuff more or less.
At the same time,
the secret history is not finished.
That's why it begins so oddly,
not with Justinian,
but with Bella's areas and Bella's areas
as wife being kicked around by his wife
Theodora and you knew some
don't know who these people are.
And then suddenly we're at Justinian.
Well, you know, the order, uh,
of this thing is not yet set.
He probably did not finish it.
Yeah,
he did, however, want it to
be published after his death.
It's called the secret history
or the, uh, neck Dota, um, uh,
sort of stories, uh, by later writers.
It survives in only one
manuscript as I think I remarked.
Nevertheless,
because it has a highly rhetorical style,
it clearly was to be read by other people.
It's not just a set of jottings
for his own satisfaction.
It is a work that he hoped would be a
widely published when he was safely dead
and enacted.
Art Literally means not stories as it
would now anecdotes that false cognate.
It means, um, not to be published.
So in the secret history
just in Ian is a monster.
What's a set that aside for a moment
and talk about what a Justinian actually
did? Justinian, uh,
was the power behind the
throne of his, um, uh,
uncle Justin the first.
Okay.
So in a way his rule goes back to
the five twenties to the five teens
Justinian's character as portrayed by
per copious in both the wars and in the
secret history is very smart,
hardworking.
A copy of says he almost never slept,
devoted to details,
capable of immersing himself in
many different things. Architecture,
Church ceremonies,
theology and law.
He was of humble birth.
His uncle,
his family were soldiers.
They were from modern.
Oh Croatia.
More or less the Balkan peninsula,
the former Yugoslavia Elyria as would
have been the term used at the time.
He grew up speaking some
form of Latin and he is,
as I said last time,
the last emperor whose native language
was Latin as opposed to Greek.
He dressed very simply
and he was approachable.
He did not have that or inspiring
splendor of Diocletian Constantine for
example,
he was seldom angry,
but he was cold and seems to have
had no trace of mercy or kindness.
Reminds me of some professors of mine.
He was intolerant, he was
unforgiving, and he was merciless.
He had a grandiose conception of
the empire and he was willing to,
um,
tax his subjects heavily and to endanger
the security of the eastern frontier in
order to expand his
territory and his prestige.
I think that is a fair judgment to Mac.
He believed that his predecessors
had nick through neglect,
lost what the ancient
Romans had conquered.
And you believed that you couldn't call
it the Roman Empire if all it consisted
of were possessions and
the eastern Mediterranean.
And as we've said,
he did indeed conquer at
great cost North Africa,
parts of Spain and Italy.
He had a, I think it's wrong
to use the term totalitarian,
but certainly a very strong
conception of imperial rulership.
He tried to impose doctrines on the
church in order to resolve the age old
Manasseh side question.
Okay.
He was no more successful than
Constantina Theodosius by the way.
But for example,
just to give you a sense of his methods,
he kidnapped the Pope in Rome,
tried to brow beat him, uh,
and exiled him to the Crimean peninsula.
He died
Theodora one of the most interesting
things about Justinian is,
uh, that he gave so much power and uh, uh,
respect to his consort Theodora who was
of even more humble birth then he was
now,
I don't think we have to believe per
copious on the details of the doors.
Youth.
He certainly reserves
his most are hysterical.
Diatribes for Theodora.
I think it's fair to say that for copious
was not a great admirer of a competent
women.
Uh,
the historian burry a JB Barry,
one of the great historians of Leighton
Rome and Byzantium who wrote it about a
hundred 120 years ago, uh,
describes her youth as stormy.
Um, an adjective that I like
because it could be anything.
Her stormy youth,
probably her father was a bear keeper.
Somebody who kept bears for the
entertainment of people at the circus,
an animal trainer.
She was the mother of a legitimate child.
Uh,
she may have had a background of
amateur or cuase I professional semipro
prostitution.
Notice that per copious condemns her
first for being a prostitute and then for
suppressing prostitution
once you became empress. Uh,
there's a logic to that per copious
is not opposed to prostitution.
One has the sense that he's, if not
a connoisseur, at least a, um, uh,
you know, uh, uh, now and then a partaker.
But for prostitutes to be
anything other than this, uh,
firmly subordinated class that is for
prostitutes to have some sort of voice or
opinion or, uh, for people to, um,
endeavored to help them or
respect them is, uh, in his mind,
uh,
ridiculous and scandalous
per copious is a conservative.
He doesn't like the weakening
of the senatorial classes.
He represents the land owning interests.
He doesn't like too much imperial power.
He's quite happy to respect the emperor,
but is angry when the emperor
seems to be taxing rich people.
He doesn't like upstarts.
Upstarts like Justinian,
who is he? Who is he? Soldiers,
child upstarts like Theodora
upstarts like a, um,
Antonio,
the wife of Bella's Iris Justinian
and Theodora ruled as a team.
They had very different personalities.
They're very interesting team.
Theodore loved sleep.
Luxury
us was sympathetic them an awful sites.
Justinian was completely the opposite and
insomniac when somebody who dressed in
a extremely ordinary clothing
and a firmly anti man officer,
they in fact supported different
factions in the circus. I mean,
here's a, you know, uh, um, uh, giants,
jets, marriage, uh, the circus,
the circus was a arena,
uh,
attached to the palace where the emperor
would make his appearances at sporting
events. Although we've said Justinian
was approachable. By that we mean that,
um, you know, people in
the government or, uh,
in high positions could see
him without too much ceremony.
That doesn't mean he's approachable just
to anybody in an absolute test state.
There's certain kinds of events at
which the ruler has to show himself or
traditionally shows himself.
So, uh, in the Soviet era,
the May Day parades,
and it was a reviewing stand in Moscow
at the tomb of Lennon and foreign
correspondence and intelligence,
people would try to see who was in and
out of power by who appeared with the
leader, who wasn't there,
where they were standing. Uh,
the hippodrome, the, um, um,
horse racing arena in
Constantinople was a bit like this.
The emperor had his own box and the
people could make sort of celebratory
gestures to him,
praise him.
And if they were in a rebellious mood,
criticized him as well.
There were circus factions,
as they're called.
That is people who were curing
for one side or another.
The most important of
which in Constantinople are
the blues and the Greens.
The Greens tended to be
somewhat probe an office site.
And Theodora was a partisan of the
grains of blues anti-money office site.
Justinian was a partisan
of there in five 32.
These circus factions revolted.
Partly it's a tax revolt.
Partly it's,
uh, uh, factions fighting.
It doesn't do to try to probe what
these factions represented too much.
After a while,
they're simply factions.
There's simply people who liked to fight
or who like to root for one side or
another, but they, um,
are rowdy and even criminal may
have very outlandish costumes.
Uh,
they expend all their money and all
their energy on sporting events and on
rowdiness a sort of associated with them.
Uh, this is not completely unfamiliar.
Uh,
the prefect of the city arrested seven
people for rioting and condemned them to
death. Uh, two of them escaped.
When the rope broke.
It always pays to maintain your,
I mean, this is a tip
from a historian, uh,
always pays to maintain
your coercive equipment. Uh,
once these guys escaped,
then they were heroes and they
were shielded from the crowd.
They were put in a monastery where they
had sanctuary and conveniently enough,
one was a blue and one was a green.
So the blues and the Greens United,
they ran through the streets
demanding pardon for the, uh, escaped
the escapees. And when Justinian
refused a riot took place,
the battle cry of these
rioters was victory,
right? Nika, not to be confused.
What sporting equipment?
Nika victory. The crowds tried to
overthrow Justinian and Theodora.
And in the process they
burned down a lot of the city.
Um,
Justinian is reported by per
copious as being ready to flay,
but Theodora stiffened his resolve,
basically telling them she preferred to
die in the shroud of the imperial robes
rather than flee in
disguise and mobilized.
Uh,
the generals blows areas and narcis
we've met Bella's areas already
and they cracked down on the mob
and killed maybe 40,000 of them.
Right? How many people attend the
Yankee Games? About 80,000. So,
um,
yeah,
30, 40,000 people. And
at that ended the riots,
Constantinople was partially burned.
Justinian loved building.
This was a great opportunity. He
couldn't have asked for a better, uh, um,
moment in a sense, a, of
course it required more taxes,
but people now I hadn't seen both
problems with resisting taxes.
And so this is where we start the building
of the new Iso Fia that we see today.
Okay.
Built in five years.
And I mean,
compare this to grand, uh,
projects like, you know, uh,
an exit on the Connecticut Turnpike,
which take 15 years or so. Uh,
the way you build something in five years,
it's by an incredible
number of workman, um, and,
uh,
lavish expenditure of money.
The patriarchs thrown in,
Aya Sophia was made of silver,
weighed 40,000 pounds.
The columns are porphyry,
many of them,
uh, it uses a lot of glass
in order to admit light.
And the light comes from so far away
that it forms these wonderful patterns
depending on the time of day.
Justinian also rebuilt
the senate, the baths, uh,
the imperial palace and the
Church of Saint, uh, Irene,
the Church of the apostles,
et Cetera, et cetera.
He started his wars against Persia
before the Nika revolt and the war with
Persia is one episode of a
multisensory war in this case.
It's over influence in the caucuses,
but it's really about trying to protect
Byzantium from Persian invasion.
But as I said, Justinian's
interest was not really in Persia.
He was interested in,
uh,
peace with Persia and in securing enough
of the frontier so that the Persians
couldn't launch, uh, at least
not easily a surprise attack.
And in five 31,
the eastern Roman Empire and
Persia signed a perpetual peace
and Justinian then moved
his troops to the west.
The sight of his real ambitions,
the vandal war in North
Africa was a triumph.
What we're seeing is one of those cases
in which a policy seems to succeed
miraculously easy.
The vandals fell.
It seemed without a fight here,
the people who had been the
terror of Rome 120 years earlier,
uh,
a hundred and a hundred years earlier
who had sacked Rome in four 55 who had
seized the grainery of realm
in four 30, uh, fell almost.
It seemed without a fight, true.
The native Berber population,
um, who were subordinate to
the vandals desert people, uh,
revolted, uh, and they, uh,
were able to raid the coast and to
undermine the position of the, uh,
the Byzantine occupiers.
The next stop was Italy in five 35,
five 33,
five 30 for the conquest of Africa.
But Italy would take 20 years,
not one. And in the process,
Italy itself would be devastated.
And with that devastation,
a lot of classical culture would be lost.
What wasn't destroyed by
the fifth century invasions.
And remember we said the Ostrogoths,
we're pretty, uh, uh, reasonable.
Uh,
occupiers would be destroyed
by the Romans themselves.
Okay.
I will not, uh, uh,
tax you with the INS and outs and
ups and downs of this campaign.
Suffice it to say that the General Bella's
areas at first was able to triumph in
Italy. The Ostrogoths
pick resistance, however,
proved to be much stronger
than he expected. And, um,
uh,
Justinian recalled Bella's areas,
almost all of Italy was reoccupied by
the Ostrogoths and it was only the second
general Narcisse who from five 52 to
five 55 is able to take over Italy.
Um,
five 40 is the year that Ravenna falls
to the Byzantines and it seems to be the
zenith of Justinian's reign.
In that year,
the Persians invaded that perpetual
peace had lasted nine years,
and the Persian invasion was,
uh,
quite successful.
It resulted in the sac of the largest
city of the empire after Constantinople
and Alexandria,
the city of Antioch
in the eastern Mediterranean.
And this was followed then by a plague,
the so called Justinian Anik plague,
which seems to be related perhaps to
the plague of paraclese Athens or the
Athens of the Peloponnesian war and
maybe to the black death of 1348,
1349 hard to say. And in fact, uh,
research now being done
on the DNA in mass graves,
uh,
from that plague will perhaps tell
us what the disease really was.
Although so far,
apparently it hasn't.
Okay.
So from five 40 to five 65,
the death of Justinian,
his policies are officially successful.
Five 55, the fall of Italy, the
plague eventually goes away,
or the Persians are pushed
out of Antioch at least.
But the empire in the later years of
Justinian is clearly staggering under the
weight of taxation,
economic downturn,
declining population. And, uh,
overextension they had conquered Italy,
but the Italy they had
conquered was ruined.
Okay.
And this empire stretching now from
Sicily to the Persian frontier is,
um,
as clearly a too big to hold on to.
So this is some of what pro copious is.
Anger is about.
Uh,
but um,
yeah,
he is, uh, he's bitter and
disillusioned, he says,
but I grow dizzy when I write of such
suffering and pass onto future times.
It's memories here.
He's speaking about the Persian
invasion of Antioch for Canada.
Understand why it is the will of God to
exalt the fortunes of a man or place and
then cast them down for
no reason that we can see.
Okay.
Now, if you contrast him with what you've
read in Augustine and the confessions,
you can see that Augustine has
some reasons why this happens.
A pro copious resists the
Christian explanation here,
and this has led some observers to think
in general that he's not really somehow
a Christian.
He is,
but he's writing in a classical
tradition and he is also remember not an
elitist,
a conservative.
I use the term elitist in
a fairly neutral sentence.
It's hard to expect someone who's writing
is come down to us all this length of
time to be somehow an ordinary person.
Yes,
he represents a class but doesn't
really like religious controversy.
That doesn't really like all of the,
um,
fussing about the natures
or nature of Christ.
But there are other things that are
not in for copious that are somewhat
surprising.
Justinian is best known for
architectural monuments like Aya,
Sophia to historians for what we're
essentially talking about today,
the Western conquest at for his legal
reforms that just any antic law code,
which is the basis of all European law,
European that is as opposed to Anglo
American Anglo American law is a separate
tradition.
European law is based ultimately on
a reworking of Roman law precedents.
So I want to talk a little bit
about his legal accomplishment,
which per copia is a,
a man who would be familiar with
law courts, with legal systems, uh,
doesn't tell us anything about
in his works, virtually nothing.
Okay.
Justinian essentially
codified the Roman law.
And this is not
only because it's the
basis of European law,
but law is related to political
and administrative order.
However much we may hate bureaucracy
or denounce administration,
that is how governments, uh, uh,
provide whatever it is they're
providing for their citizens.
And the, since the alternative
to government is anarchy,
and since they're examples before
our eyes of anarchic societies,
it won't do to underestimate
the benefits of law.
However cynical we may be
about its implementation.
Roman law at the time of
Justinian was as law tends to be,
um,
learned and unwieldy.
If you wanted to know how
to resolve a question,
you could go through the thousands and
thousands of what are called response.
Or You could look at legislation just
as in the Anglo American tradition.
And some of you will learn
this very soon in law school.
You can either look at statutes
passed by legislatures or court cases,
precedents, the equivalent
of a statute. You know,
Connecticut passes a law saying that
you can't have a gun in your car.
Uh,
whereas Texas has laws that say you can
have a gun in your car under such and
such circumstances. Okay, so you
have a whole set of statute law,
which would be imperial
statutes in the Roman Empire,
imperial legislation,
or
if the statutes don't cover a particular
situation or you want something that
has the particularity,
uh,
my tree, a tree on my property
falls on my neighbors.
Did I mention this already? Yeah,
that one. Uh, on my neighbor's garage,
um, you know, who's, who's to
blame. Okay. You go and you say,
well,
you know,
at this case came up in a Cincinnati in
1949 and this is what the judge found in
the absence of computers.
The search for this stuff is very
hard in a Anglo American law.
This is called precedents.
In Roman law,
they're called response.
And interestingly enough,
this term is also singular,
plural replied to Jewish law.
A response is a response.
A judge, an expert,
a law professor in effect,
is asked his opinion on something and
his response becomes preserved as a kind
of precedent.
These were voluminous and represented
centuries of law and even more.
Of course, the response of conflicted
one judge says, you have to pay,
uh, because it was your tree.
Another says, uh, um, uh,
it's an accident.
He's responsible for his own remedies.
What do you do if you have a
conflict of judges? What if you do,
if you have two kinds of
contradictory responses,
you've got to decide who takes who is
more authoritative, which one is better.
So the work of Justinian's compilers
was to sort out legislation,
statutes and the responses and also
to decide among contradictory ones,
what is in this law.
Well,
what's in any law we think of law as
having mostly to do with criminals and
stuff like that.
But criminal law is actually very simple.
It's like the Burgundian code.
If you murder someone,
this is what's going to happen to you.
There may be different kinds of killing
if you murder them with intent and
premeditation,
that's worse than if you murdered them
in a fight and spontaneous like, um,
it is, uh, man slaughter
is different from murder.
Manslaughter is where you didn't intend
to kill the person. Uh, but you did,
you punched him and you didn't know
that he had a weak heart and he died.
That's manslaughter. Um, you know, you
punched him, you intended to hurt him,
but you didn't intend to kill him, but
he died. Um, vehicular manslaughter,
you know, uh, what's the
difference between negligence?
You should have seen something and
you didn't versus criminal intent.
You did it deliberately.
Um,
okay.
But it's very simple.
The criminal law,
there aren't a whole lot of gray areas
and you can get through the criminal code
pretty quickly.
But what about contracts?
What about property? This
is endless. This is endless.
So, um, you know, in law
school, criminal law will be,
um, you know, the cream or the, um,
the tip of the proverbial iceberg
or some little side issue.
Most of your time is going to be spent
on those of you who go for this option
on, um, no property and contracts.
And that's what the extend Ian law
is mostly property and contracts,
legal arrangements for buying and selling,
inheriting partnerships,
Guardian ships,
security,
surety obligations.
This is a very advanced
science in Roman law.
As advanced as it is anywhere at any time,
it's very different from,
you cut off one finger,
you pay five solid day,
which we were looking at last week.
The work that ensued,
the so called Justinian a code
or the Corpus Yoris civil is
the body of civil law,
uh, was drawn up in
five years. Here again,
is an example of unbelievable rapidity
compared with the length of time it takes.
Now, uh, uh, you know, merely to, uh,
reform the Connecticut tax code or the
to den Connecticut Traffic Code for that
matter. Um, it was
undertaken by a commission.
Yeah,
four books were issued.
Okay.
The first is a collection of
statutes and it's called the codex
collected laws of the Senate and
imperial laws of previous centuries.
The largest book is The d,
The digest or in Latin Digesta.
The digest is
the weeded out response.
Sir organized by subject.
So this would be where you would go to
try and figure out what happens if a
river changes its course
a little and your land,
uh, is it seems to be now
taken over by your neighbor.
Is the river the border or is align,
uh, on artificial line? The morning,
the third book is a kind of textbook or
a survey of the whole law and what it's
supposed to mean called the institutes.
And the fourth is called the novella
or new laws because obviously new laws
would have to be made.
Okay.
The Codex,
the digest,
the institutes are in Latin because Latin
was the language of the Roman Empire.
But the novella are in Greek because
Greek was the language of the empire.
Now now being five 34 when
this work was finished,
the Justinian code is more however
than a rearrangement of old laws.
It displayed a consistent
philosophy of government
where law is more than precedent.
It is an active force in society.
The emperor is seen as the servant of
the law, the implementer of the law,
but he's also the master of the law.
He is an absolute power.
He is the embodiment of the law.
This is a well
run,
immense burden.
Some empire pro copious
gives us unreliable though
he may be as to Justinian
being a demon,
et cetera.
Copious gives us a vivid
picture of a highly governed,
even efficiently governed,
but oppressively governed
and very ambitious society.
Now for next week and a little bit after,
remember we have no class on Wednesday.
We have class on Monday and you're
going to read from Gregory of tour,
uh,
about Clovis and the Franks and it will
seem more violent and more primitive
than what we've been reading. But
violence in primitiveness, unfortunately,
are part of history and
government at almost any time. Uh,
so enjoy the intrigue.
I'm not going to test you on the names.
You'll see there lots of great cat names,
uh,
of the Frankish barbarians.
Uh,
but pay attention to the figure of
Clovis and to the attitude of Gregory,
because as with per copious,
we've got an interesting,
if not completely reliable source.